This enables us to create a full capture of the scene
from any perspective.
Now this renders a fully light-immersive scene
from multiple perspectives.
This capability requires an insane amount of information to be processed.
We will have to capture the light from an enormous amount of cameras
to create this information.
Now, in order to do such a thing,
we would need a setup that would host a numerous amount of cameras
installed in a stage
and a stage big enough in order to fit a full cinematic experience.
Now that sounds like a crazy idea, but that's exactly what we did.
For the last three years,
we have been building a huge volumetric camera chamber.
It's 10,000 square feet of a stage,
enabling to capture the action from any location.
We have deployed hundreds of cameras,
sending a tremendous amount of information
to a huge data center powered by Intel supercomputers.
The ability to have this 10,000 feet
enables us to fit any kind of action,
any kind of performance.
It is the size of an average Broadway stage.
We call it Intel Studios,
and it's the largest volumetric stage in the world,
with the objective of enabling and exploring
the next generation of this immersive media filmmaking.
Now, to test these ideas,
we were thinking about what we can do as the first scene to try it out.
So we chose the Western scene.
We brought horses, set designers, dirt,
everything needed to create the full scene of a Western.
But this time, there was no camera inside.
There was nothing really moving besides all the cameras
installed outside.
The challenge of the actors was tremendous.
They have to perform a flawless action visible from all the directions.
There's no possibility to hide a punch or not show the action.
Everything is captured and everything is seen.
The output of the capture --
this is our future capture --
opened our eyes for the immense capabilities.
It was like a full 3D scan of the entire scene.
We were able to move around and travel in the space.
The thing about this,
it's not anymore about perceiving the light emitted from a screen
but now traveling inside the light,
traveling inside the scene.
This obviously opens possibilities for an enormous amount
of storytelling and methodologies of creation.
This is the possibilities of your personal narrative,
the possibility of creating your own story inside,
or maybe following other stories.
Let's take a look at one of the last renders and see.
(Music)
What you're seeing here is full volumetric video,
and there's no physical camera in the scene.
(Music)
We have the full control
(Music, sounds of combat)
of space and time.
Now, again, no physical camera was here.
Everything was captured surrounding.
Now, this is very nice,
but what if we wanted to see the scene, maybe, from the eyes of the horse?
Well, we can do that as well.
(Horse galloping)
So what you're seeing right now is the same action,
but this time, we're watching exactly from the eyes of the horse.
The possibilities are, well, unlimited.
(Applause)
Thank you.
So this is all great for creators and storytellers.
It really opens a huge canvas
for a different type of storytelling and moviemaking.
But what about the audience?
How can the audience experience this differently?
In order to [create] our explorations,
we partnered with Paramount Pictures
in order to explore immersive media in a Hollywood movie production.
Together with the director Randal Kleiser,
we reimagined the iconic movie of 1978,
"Grease."
Some of you know it, some of you don't.
A 40-year-old movie, amazing experience.
And our goal was really to look at how we can take this iconic action and dance
and bring it deeper into the experience,
bring it deeper into the audience.
Imagine that you can not just watch the movie
but get inside it and dance with the actors
and dance with the performance.
Now we're breaking, really, the traditional 2D mindset of thinking,
and bringing a much richer possibility of moviemaking
and content creation.
But why watch it on the screen?
Let's try to bring these actors here on the stage.
So they're not going to really come --
I'm going to use an iPad.
(Laughter)
Sorry.
I'm going to use an iPad in order to bring in augmented reality.
Now, obviously, these devices have their own limitations
in terms of the data-computing process,
so we have to reduce the amount of resolution.
So what I'm doing now, I'm placing here a marker,
so I'll be able to position exactly where I want everyone to appear.
OK.
I think we have them here.
(Applause)
John Travolta, or --
(Laughter)
a version of him.
Let's take a look.
(Video) Female: Hey.
Male: And that is how it's done.
Female: Your turn.
Male: Hey, guys! Check this out.
(Song: "You're the one that I want")
Danny: Sandy!
Sandy: Tell me about it, stud.
(Singing) I got chills. They're multiplying
And I'm losing control
'Cause the power you're supplying
It's electrifying!
(Video ends)
(Applause and cheers)
Diego Prilusky: Thank you.
So as you can see,
we can watch and experience content in the traditional way
or in an immersive way.
Really, the possibilities are open.
We're not trying to change or replace movies.
We're enhancing them.
The technologies enable new possibilities to start thinking beyond the flat screen.
We're in immersive and really exciting times in filmmaking.
We're at the threshold of a new era.
We're opening the gates for new possibilities
of immersive storytelling,
and exploration and defining what immersive media filmmaking means.
We're really just at the beginning,
and we invite you all to join us.
Thank you.
(Applause)